- Des manifestants
violentes, prêts à mourir
pour leur cause et armés
jusqu'aux dents au blocage
de Coutts en Alberta :
Voilà ce qui a convaincu le
ministre de la Sécuré é publique
qu'il fallait invoquer la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence.
au ministre Marco Mendicino
L'information révélée
de Brenda Lucki,
commisirire de la GRC.
Des agents d'infiltration
de la police fédérale
d'une cache d'armes à feu,
m munitions et de vestes
pare-balles dans le village
frontalier où étaienttatatatatas
depuis le 29 janvier.
Pourtant, ce 13 février,
à la veille de l'invocation
d'urgence, la grande patronne
de la GRC croyaiququ'il existait
d'autres recours pour
mettre fin aux occupations
que les forces policières
avaient élororé un plan.
Plus tard, Dominic LeBlanc,
mirere des Affaires
intergouvernementales,
a affirmé à la commissionesesess
bancaires des manifestants
qui partipipent à des activités
illégales à l'extérieur
de leur province de résidence,rs
aux institutions financières
paouout au pays.
DOMINIC LeBLANC, ministre féd.
des Affaires intergouv.
économiques soient efficaces,iln
nationale. Parce que,
si quelqu'un a un comptempmpmpm,
à la caisse populaire au Québec
ou à la Banque Nationale,
ça sera pas à l'abri
des mesures économiques
nécessaires de notre jugement
pour amener ses actes illégaux
- Sorry, I'm speaking.
- Yes, sir.- Les esprits se sons
lorsque l'avocat du convoi
des camionneurs d'Ottawa
a demandé au commissaire n n n s
protégés soient décaviardés.
- You're asked to leave.
- Excédé, le commissairepupupup.
- La commission est levée.
- Le commissaire a rejeté
en partie la demande a a a a a t
du convoi des camionneurs
d'Ottawa. Des documents
qui sont protégés par
le p
seront dévoilés intégralement,
mais pas ceux protégés
par le secret du cabinet.
Brendan Miller a pu retourner
avoir offert des excuses
au commissaire.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw